my name is Greta I am John we just
watched the clip for comical island
monsters exist now we are moving on to
monster battles monsters existed well I
just learned they existed and now we're
going to bow down they're going to
battle wow they just waited spoil the
mood hey don't waste any time I was
gonna wonder the whole time are there
actually going to be monsters that show
up oh and now I know Skull Island I
probably just a spooky ass name to keep
people off keep people out you know
well this close 22 seconds long oh boy
you know and the other clip was just
characters talking about 47 seconds long
these guys are gonna do some talking
with their fists or jaws I am in maybe a
tail me go I'll be a quiet whoa
oh I see more good cool they've just got
my ticket is I was looking at the
misunderstanding there I'm like it was
pretty good it looks very good
yeah as I'm out of the coolest yeah I
can't kept wondering like what is
nature's practical reasoning for this
diamond legs a tail and a head their due
date a figure
yeah the cool fight yeah I'm really
getting like a b-movie monster vibe from
this from the two clips we saw yeah
excited about that yeah like it looks
like it's going to be a fun monster
movie like think about the two clips to
release monsters exist monsters battle
like it seems like they're really honing
in on monster by not as King Kong yeah
like a whole the monster genre yeah man
it's almost as if they're going back to
some of the classic monster movies and
reviving a whole new wave for new
generation but keeping the monsters
attacks but seriously like the visual
effects of like I'm looking at it still
right now of the Kong and it looks in
the dinosaur and it looks rather real
like in telemetry really well with the
environment they bounce it really well
with the America they shot this on
location Oh so to see this like I think
it's a fish on goes to this home
location yeah they did well the effects
are good like you text look pretty good
I know we had some quips about that in
the in the trailer been watching a
little bit more of a scene play out it
looks much better yeah and I don't know
whenever I see em finish it back to the
trailer I always sort of calm down the
movie still sounds weird
now so it's not a visual effect oh yeah
yeah so and I don't know like I don't
know if they used any miniatures or
anything other than see you but yeah I
mean like it's a cool fight it's that
same thing that we've talked about
another
monster movies lately especially you
know some the gareth edwards stuff is
like you know there is very locked into
the human perspective so it makes the
monster stuff freaky you know it seems
very opposite from Godzilla so which is
it making me excited to see these two
worlds collide actually this looks like
it's going to give you the fun yeah
what's going to be like BAM like it
seems like it's really upbeat not upbeat
but like fun it has a sense of fun but
the drum rhythm as opposed to Godzilla
which is more of a slow burn this
communicates at least you know from the
outset that maybe they understand the
fun parts of intrigue and apparel yeah
Harel can still be fun and these movies
are all about peril alright guys are you
still excited for comic alignment shout
out to you discover the real rejects
Josh uses Gerry on Twitter and Instagram
results with social media manager bloom
Houston the real reject goodbye